breakout list says what personal
efficiency or life management things do
you do on a semi-regular basis eg some
kind of life review exercise where you
rate certain categories in your life etc
the answer is none
i am lazy that way i choose to live a
spontaneous and free life
i don't want to live a very structured
life
um i know people who are married friends
of mine who are married and they
actually have quarterly meetings with
their wife and they have you know
reports and how are we performing as a
marriage and what are objectives and
what are key results and you know what's
our one year plan what's our five year
plan and
i just don't plan i'm not a planner i
prefer to live in the moment and be free
and flow and be happy
i think projecting too much in the
future
judging yourself setting yourself up in
very difficult ways other than as i
talked about just like one habit or one
desire
if you start
trying to
control yourself on a micro basis if you
try and micromanage yourself all you're
going to do is make yourself miserable
and you're gonna get nothing done so
just focus on the one or two really
really important things and everything
else
just surrender to it just take it as it
comes just accept it be happy with it be
glad that you're in this world be glad
that you're clothed and fed and that
you're not getting bombs dropped in your
head
like some people in the world are and uh
you know just
it's i think it's i think i like to stay
free because that way i can see
the little miracles in life you know and
there are little miracles everywhere
it's just we have taken them for granted
the fact that you're wearing clothes the
fact that you have enough food to eat
the fact that you're in a in a place of
shelter yes you can roll your eyes about
it yes you can say yeah that's obvious
everybody has it but actually not
everybody has it
it would be great to go take a trip to a
third world country or to a refugee camp
and see how little some other people
have
and i think it's a bad habit that we
developed that we
forget how to appreciate
what we do have and so
not obsessing about the future and not
beating yourself up over what you don't
have is very important because then you
can actually pay attention and be
grateful for what you do have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you